has been waiting to see a doctor since
the break of dawn her child is running a
fever so she comes here for help we saw
the doctor but there was no medicine
given we will have to use herbs
there are only three health facilities
in this huge refugee camp in eastern
Chad all of them poorly equipped to deal
with the emergency at hand
this is what it looks like at a field
Hospital in the chadian Border Town of
address
there are more than 55 000 people at
this refugee camp malaria is considered
a minor sickness here there are
thousands of pregnant women in the camp
and if they have to give birth they'll
have to do it here
Faisal and a few other doctors who are
also refugees at the camp volunteer to
help their fellow Sudanese
but there is a limit to how much help
they can offer we have got only one
single manometer and one is Jesus cup
this is not enough for to see Pediatric
cases and to see medicine and even
obstacles
and also we don't have a
anthropometric measurement tools even
before the influx of refugees this
Hospital in the Dre was struggling to
serve the people here and in surrounding
communities
and with a sudden increase in the
population the task is met even harder
both doctors and patients will have to
make do with what's available
back at the camp doctors fear it's only
a matter of time before an epidemic
breaks out already many worrying cases
of infectious diseases are being
reported
most of cases are of malnutrition
gastroenteritis
and there is suspicion of misses
concerning medicine there are a lot of
cases such as chronic diseases
hypertension diabetes mellitus
hygiene and waste disposal are already a
problem in this Camp of 55 000 people
the impact of any disease outbreak could
prove catastrophic
Sudan border